so the first thing is we're talking
about medians right medians are based on
midpoints and if I want to work out
midpoints on this what I'm going to do
is I'm going to impose this is what a
couple of you actually suggested to me
I'm going to impose some corner geometry
language onto here okay so I've got
three corners of the triangle right so
I'm going to call one x1 y1 I can't give
it any more you know a specific label of
that because it could be anywhere right
this could be a random point so I'm
gonna call it x2 y2 and then I guess
I'll be original and call this x3 y3 is
that all right so I've put corner
geometry structure on this okay let's
have a look at this guy over here this
particular midpoint which produces this
median that I was drawn my colors on
molecular thing how do I find out where
that midpoint is well this is pretty
simple right to find em it's the
midpoint of x1 y1 and x2 y2 can you keep
go ahead and quote that to me what's the
midpoint I'll give you a clue it starts
with an X I'll give you that one for
free tell me what else to read now this
is hilarious because literally your
class come on x1 you can do better than
this x1 what am I gonna add to that Plus
x2 I'm gonna divide by two because of
course what you are doing as we alluded
to earlier is you're finding an average
all right that's what a midpoint is in
this context
so you've average the x-coordinates and
then what else do you ever egde the
y-coordinate so we get this guy that is
the midpoint of this interval which
gives us that medium okay
now this property is saying that if you
have a look at this you should get this
ratio to one you should okay so let's
see what happens because we now know
this coordinate geometry knowledge let's
see what happens if I divide it up to
one you have a formula for this right
let's call the centroid at that point
let's call it P for point how do I vide
this up well P is going to use the ratio
division formula right what's the ratio
you've got
look two to one to anyone okay now you
you guys remember in the ratio and
division formula or what it matters
doesn't it right two to one is not the
same as one to two okay so you've got
your arm I mean you do have this on the
reference sheet but you guys are x1 I'd
like you to be able to get to that point
where you actually remember this result
depending on which way you use it so one
that I remember I love the irony being
given was this you've got an X whatever
I'm gonna put up something else there in
a second plus M X the other whatever on
M plus M do you remember this sure when
you learn you're like oh you gotta watch
out that order cuz you'll do it the
other way around if you don't get the
order correct and then you do the same
thing with the Y's right and and then
you'll like one M and then you other y
coordinate and then you add your two
parts of the ratio right now can we do
that with this particular set of points
this is the media I'm focused on the
up/down one okay we just worked out the
corner to M here are the coordinates of
the other end of the median okay so I'm
going to say let's have a look here if
I'm going to 2 1 that's 2 2 1 2 2 1 when
I look at these I have to flip them
around so that's gonna be a one and A
two A one and A two let's now substitute
this in for these particular points okay
two to one
which of the points is my starting point
to one am I gonna start here or anger
start there you carefully look at the
order of the numbers right to comes
first starting from this side and then
one okay so I have to put this guy in as
my first ratio right so it's 1 times X 3
plus 2 times now what's the x-coordinate
have a look at it I just wrote it up
above right it's this guy here yes so
I'm gonna write that in is half X 1 plus
X 2 are you ok with that
that's the x-coordinate I get from the
midpoint and I divide that all by 3 in
this case
fantastic and then I'm just gonna bring
repeat for the white corner right I've
got one from the ratio it's why three
because you told me to start up at this
point over here plus two that comes from
the ratio times 1/2 here's the other
coordinate on the bottom right all
divided again by three fantastic okay
now do you notice what's happening right
what what happens is numerator up here
that two for instance what's going on it
cancels with the half so in fact all you
get left with from this is x1 plus x2
and then all you get from this is x3 all
right x1 plus x2 plus x3 and that's all
divided by three then you've got what's
on the right-hand side is everything the
same but for wires right okay now what
have we just established well we looked
at one particular median we looked at
this midpoint we're into the opposite
side and then we did the corner sorry
the ratio division formula and this is
what we came with came up with but I
just want you to notice look at this
result
doesn't it look strange may or may be
when I say strange I mean like neat
really nice and like oh this is one of
those answers you get me and you're like
this must be the right hits are right
what we call this is it is it's
symmetric
now you're used to thinking of symmetry
like reflectional symmetry or rotational
symmetry you're stiffening of of that
kind of symmetry but this is a different
kind of symmetry I started with these
two to get the midpoint and then I went
to that but can you see I would get
exactly the same result if I hadn't have
started with this particular pair and go
to that midpoint if I gone to this
midpoint right all my numbers would be a
rearranged I wouldn't have x1 x2
I'd have look I'd have x1 x3 but do you
see I'm going to get exactly the same
thing I don't need to do this all over
again because it's symmetric result all
right I can shuffle around the ones and
twos and threes and there is no
difference whatsoever okay so your
diamond
you have just proved number one that if
you did all the medians from all the
different directions you'd still come up
with the same coordinates that means
that's the definition of them being
concurrent you just found the
coordinates of the centroid and the way
we got there is by using the ratio
division formula two to one that's what
produced this so I'm done I'm finished
one two three four lines compared to I
don't even want to count how many lines
that is not to mention the the thinking
that goes into this is just obvious like
how else do I find a midpoint how else
do i do ratio division that's it okay
yes okay very good
the question was like have I just
assumed that the ratio is two to one and
I actually have it what I've done is
I've said what if I divided it up into
two one right what if I did that and
then where would I be okay so I haven't
had we actually established by just by
doing two to one that that's going to be
the centroid but then when I look at the
result that I get after doing it two to
one I find that this thing will be the
same if I went from that side or from or
from that side they're all going to give
me the same point and that means they
are all concurrent so I've used this as
my sort of like stepping stone right and
then I've proved the rest of it if that
makes sense okay good question